hello this is another one by dr. Sanford
chalk and talk video responses and in
this one I am responding yet again to
the questions asked you a very
interesting question one that's a bit
personal actually for me as a
philosopher necessarily needs into
talking about some more Turing's of good
some understandings of goods or in
someone's life so the question is what
is your favorite thing about life so far
and that's an interesting question I am
40 years old so I at what you say is the
peak in some ways right they say it's
all downhill from here as far as mental
acuity to go for philosophers historians
people are working the manatees actually
you're still on the rise until they say
15 16 sometimes even seventies
physically though you are inclined and
it's also a good age in part because by
the time that you're 40 you've
experienced most likely quite a few ups
and downs you've experienced some
successes setbacks you have embraced and
endorsed goods which turned out to be
somewhat like fools gold not quite as
valuable as you assume they worried they
have sacrificed some goods that appeared
to be more worthwhile for other goods
you have learned some valuable life
lessons you've also hopefully by the
time you're 40 you seen a lot of other
people go through these as well
reflecting on their experience so that
opens up the possibility ignite of
developing and better appreciation of
what we call ethics and the very broad
sense of how should you structure your
life how should you arrange the goods
and bad things within your my Pasha
order the motion to rank them how should
you prioritize them that would so being
four years old opens up the possibility
of seeing things about somewhat clearer
light that when I was 20 than when I was
30 so what is your favorite thing about
life so far the answer to that for me at
one point was studying philosophy and
uncovering the thoughts and the
dialogues and interplay many brilliant
minds now actually
if I have to give an answer them it
might be different 10 years ago well
what is my favorite thing about life so
far I would say the purses my life I
have learned that people are more
important than ideas that there is a
greater value that was eyes each person
that there is any abstraction and that
ultimately what makes life most valuable
is developing relationships now it is a
also sort of cattle back I am planning a
Christian philosophers so God is with
somewhere in there I'll also admit that
God is certainly at this point in my
life much less sensual than within that
ordering of persons than god I want to
be survey if I compare myself to the
philosophers who I work out like cindy
had song and st. Thomas Aquinas and
earlier Christian philosophers like
Hillary
yeah I mean that was made let's talk
some philosophy so we have a lot of
varieties of goods that's going to play
it's a whole lot of varieties of goods
there are many different ways in which
we understand the multiplicity of goods
and the listing that I'm choosing here
is actually taken apart from the way in
which people like dietrich von
Hildebrand have fun using some of their
will be happy but also some of that era
stato uses I'm also taking something
from Alice traumatic tire or is not the
originator of this idea classically to
distinguish the heads of the categories
so what are some of the big candidate
needful things that are necessary things
that like a cue software some sort of
evil some of these are so basic that
laughing you got food water adequate
shelter some of them may take you a
while to lack of health ultimately
reduces your time of life and also
reduces the quality there are certain
goods that you need in order to have a
place where
enjoy other goods but they they're not
particularly great in and of themselves
you know you could you could live off
the very adult diet but that would be
something very different than pleasant
things would be needful things we've got
customized now think of all the
different pleasant things that you have
experienced were I do that and I
actually run them through my mind we
would need a lot of hours of denia me
just sitting here thinking remember it
imagine there are many different
pleasant things and i'm ignoring the
factory right now that we find different
things closet that perhaps you don't
enjoy cigars the way that I do for the
taste of the bitter stout the way that I
do I mean I'm joy tastes of something
the way to do and certainly I would find
very few people who share exactly my
taste in music or literature or art not
that big of a problem point us there are
many different plus of things that's
that's not much to consider the range in
place there are other things that we can
look back over time and say you know I
thought that was a bad thing at the time
but it was necessary for my growth
necessary in a different way than
needful needful things if you don't have
them you know
certain ways a lot to experience of good
there other things that provide you with
what you like setbacks or frustrations
but they're needed in order to allow you
to develop you know for example one of
the things that I do agree with Lawrence
Kohlberg on is that if you wanna think
about the world's development one of the
ways in which we do develop early is
through conduct when we disagree with
each other and we have to defend our
refuse out situations we say that person
is a bad person because they did this
this and this and that's bad because of
this business and then somebody else has
no no you're wrong about that then we
think about and sometimes we are you
know I've had the experience for example
of actually being kicked out of my
mentors office one time when back when I
was a deconstructionist and I was
pulling on some der Biddy and things i
hate he just totally get out here and i
was shocked her and surprised but i did
and that was actually an important
moment in my in my development so there
are many things in Vegas not all of our
painful then there are what we can call
intrinsically good things and again I'm
not worried about the fact that we find
different things intrinsically good that
appreciate things differently that there
may be some aspects of some objects that
you grasp that I don't get and vice
versa there are some things that are
intrinsically good that we refine the
goodness the goodness that is the air in
and not just because they're plus not
just
they're necessary now just because
they're useful for something there is
something compelling about there's
something that reaches out to us
something that impresses that Thomas and
there can also be some things that are
intrinsically evil or there could be
intrinsically good things that are very
vulnerable oh maybe catch sense of that
vulnerability we want to protect it but
the idea is that there are some things
whose goodness resides in now some
philosophers like to say oh there's one
one thing that's intrinsically good a
good will I don't accept that I don't
buy that phenomenon of value like akshay
learn from hildenbrand don't accept that
either neither an heiress on Aristotle
doesn't think that everything is merely
because of then there are also goods
that have to be shared there are some
goods that you cannot experience on your
own or you cannot produce on your own or
you do not fully enjoy under or you
cannot explore their deaths for instance
you can play a game of chess with
yourself and you can study the openings
of great masters but there's no
substitute for a man
across the board so they don't I'm not a
good chess player I don't actually
appreciate team sports are like you need
other people in order to play soccer
enjoy that that one I can't understand
even it really had a good fight somebody
did you get a burger who you can find
with it a certain way don't you although
that may not be quite so good but there
are certain goods that can only be
experienced with others and maybe even
others with the right sort others for
the right temper than others who are in
the right sense of relationships I think
that we can you know think that very
very garage earns about you know the
answer is what's the best thing about
life so far what's the treasure too good
when you experience it really is it
physically we go through a little range
goods there's some that are merely
useful to get us some other things think
about for example well I wealth is not
good get it on itself you know here's a
dollar bill it's pretty but it's
prettiest but what he has not compared
to only its greenest is not really a
function of its usefulness system
crumble up line is just as good as one
like this not good for very much who
might know a thing either is it there
are things that are present right and
there's this perhaps of the gradation
maybe some things are pleasant or become
closet because first they're useful that
made them experience them and then there
are physically good things and it's lots
of insurance if the good things are not
pleasant but you don't like them just
because they're closed and even think
about this with several things Aristotle
for example talks about three kinds of
friendship yeah he talks about in terms
of friendship useful and pleasant than
any talks about terms of virtue but we
could use similar terms being
intrinsically good appreciating the
person for who they are appreciating
your ear connection with them for what
it is not just something pleasant and I
would say that the relationships that I
had in my life with good friends with
colleagues with my children with my
family and with my wife to be fitted to
that category of the intrinsically good
even if they're not always pleasant and
sometimes they actually are quite the
opposite of useful sometimes they
require a lot of you these are all
different things these are all different
goods or values that the people have
looked at over time I would like
actually to close this by talking about
somebody who saw you know God and
persons is very important that we saw
I'd use for all the rest of these but
decided that wisdom was best and that is
the King Solomon at least as far as we
know
through through scripture which might be
a little bit overwhelmed but but you
know he's credited as being a
philosophical tonight and I think that
he really is here's how the story goes
that these with one of her versions God
actually says to them what do you want
i'm going to give you any one of these
you pick any thanks and then he says
this is a bad job that you've got me
with this this huge numerous people that
seem to be completely unmanageable i'm
going to need some wisdom if i'm not
going to totally screwed up that's what
the chronicles paraphrase a little bit
and then guys has already picked the
right one you not only get wisdom you
get the rest as well there's something
to them you pick wisdom because it was
useful but he also picked wisdom because
he desired because there was something
there that drew him that that you know
unfolded itself and its really
interesting in the biblical text where
wisdom is personified wisdom unfolds for
riches to the one who seek sir and it's
nothing Pleasant but there's also
intrinsic value too now here's where it
gets really means can you pursue bizim
by yourself yeah and you can but isn't
it so much better when you do it